[Musique]
dans les années 80 j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un professeur un linguiste qui
s'appelle pierre juba et qui un matin
nous a raconté une anecdote tôt début de
kuran ont fuit à peu près la taille de
celui ci l'anecdote était la suivante
pierre juba on nous a expliqué que il
rentrait d'une soirée chez des amis à
rennes il traversait la ville à un
moment il va arriver un carrefour il y
avait un feu tricolore
le feu était au rouge il s'arrête et
puis il attend que le feu passe au vert
et puis là tant il attend et puis le feu
passe pas au vert visiblement quelque
chose ne fonctionnait pas je vends y
regarde à gauche
il regarde à droite et il passe et à ce
moment-là gyrophare voiture de police
bloquée sur le côté on descend
rapidement et là donc c'est toujours
l'histoire racontée par pierre gibaud
vierge du banc nous dit qu'il a commencé
a expliqué aux policiers que il ne
voyait pas de bonnes raisons pour
lesquelles il allait se laisser dicter
son comportement par un robot qui
visiblement était défectueux c'était un
excellent orateur un piège du banc et et
je les imagine en train d'expliquer ça à
la police ça devait être extrêmement
amusant
et puis nous expliquant ça nous
étudiants on se marrait parce que c'est
vraiment si je suis bon jugement a fait
son show du bon et ben non je pense pas
maintenant je pense pas à dire que plus
de 30 ans après je pense que juba il
essayait de nous faire passer un message
extrêmement important extrêmement simple
que j'ai mis plus de trente ans à
comprendre
il essayait de nous expliquer que
lorsqu'on était en face de machines et
était extrêmement important de toujours
se poser la question du est ce que la
machine et est une et à une place que je
lui accorde
et est ce que ce que la machine suggère
je suis dans l'obligation de l'accepter
ou pas et donc est sûr qu'en 2019 le
sujet de la robotique d'une façon
générale un qu'on parle de robot
mécanique on parle d'algorithmes qu'on
parle d'intelligence artificielle
tout ça se pose d'une façon certainement
beaucoup plus compréhensible plus
immanente que que dans les années 80 et
je pense qu'il est très important que
nous nous posions tous ces questions là
quand on se pose la question du pourquoi
le robot qui est ici et ici
est-ce que je l'acceptent donc qu'est ce
que c'est que des robots il ya plein de
sortes de robots et à placer deux robots
par exemple si vous avez besoin de faire
un calcul un peu compliqué 4q les
racines de 10 je pense que pas beaucoup
d'entre vous sont capables de le faire
de tête ou utilisé un robot qui savait
du calculatrice ça existe depuis
longtemps et ça fonctionne
merveilleusement bien et personne ne va
remettre en cause l'existence est
l'intérêt de la calculatrice
si vous voulez aller chercher des pièces
irradiés dans le coeur d'une centrale
nucléaire vous allez utiliser un petit
rover un autre type de robot et personne
va remettre en cause
et puis il ya d'autres cas qui sont qui
sont plus limites
par exemple par exemple par exemple je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez dans dans
charlie et la chocolaterie
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez du
métier du père de charlie père de
charlie il travaille dans une usine qui
fabrique des tubes de dentifrice et son
métier en au bout de chaîne c'est de
prendre le bouchon du tube de dentifrice
et le vice est en haut du tube de
dentifrice et il est très content de
faire ça le père de charlie c'est pas la
seule activité pour sa vie mais il
trouve que comme métier c'est bien
visiblement il est content dans le film
et puis un jour on voit arriver dans
l'usiné il ya des types qui pousse comme
ça une t'appuies sur la table il ya un
bras mécanique et on prend le bras
mécanique et on le met à la place du
père de charlie qui rendent chez lui
plus de boulot et donc quand je vous
raconte ça j'imagine que vous dites
voilà le patron du père charli il a fait
ça pour prendre les revenus du père de
charlie et puis se les mettre dans la
poche et vous vous dites pour tient là
on est en train de m'expliquer que le
patron c'est un vilain mais je pense pas
du tout que ce soit un bien moi en tout
cas c'est sûr qu'il n'ait pas pu bien
que moi et sûrement pas plus vite vous
je pense que que le patron du père de
charlie il a juste oublié de se poser la
question quelle société je construis en
faisant cela
c'est à dire que le père de charlie les
je pense comme beaucoup d'entre nous
dans une espèce de tradition qui fait
que quand quelque chose devient
techniquement technologiquement possible
au considère que ça devient
immédiatement acceptable ce qui est
sûrement une réaction qui a permis
beaucoup de progrès pendant un siècle et
demi mais en 2019 bf je vous ai pas dit
moi je fabrique des robots dans la vie
c'est mon métier donc en 2019 je me pose
sérieusement cette question est ce que
le fait que quelques choses deviennent
possibles est suffisant pour le rendre
souhaitable
donc il ya plein d'exemples dans notre
quotidien des types de robots il y en a
plein prenons par exemple aujourd'hui
aussi si je m'achète un article sur
internet
je passe ma commande la commune et va
sur un robot qui va s'occuper de la
logistique ça va être un robot et puis à
la fin une fois j'aurais passé ma
comment on va me dire ah tu as aimé ce
bouquin et bien peut-être que ce film va
te plaire
le tel autre livre c'est drôlement
tentant de dire mais oui peut-être
sauf que c'est encore un robot qui me
proposent ça et est ce robot là en plus
c'est un robot qui est basé que sur le
conformisme
en vrai il analyse les comportements
pour voir en quoi ils sont homogènes et
donc c'est une espèce de machine à
fabriquer de la conformité donc donc
c'est peut-être bien mais ça vaut le
coup de se poser la question au cirque
eux ne pensez surtout pas que j'essaie
de vous expliquer qu'il faut séparer des
robots ce que j'essaie très bon je vous
livre ma réflexion actuelle qui est
posons nous la question c'est à dire que
en faisant ce que nous faisons on est en
train de construire une société avec une
forme particulière quand je poste un
message sur un réseau social je l'envoie
pas du tout à mes amis je le vois un
robot qui lui va décider en fonction de
règles qui lui appartiennent et qui
servent les propos de personnes que je
connais pas qu'ils vivent a décidé de
dispatcher de dispatcher se passer ce
message
il ya pas mal d'années
hannah arendt quand elle a écrit sur sur
le totalitarisme
elle a défini totalitarisme comme un
système qui cherche systématiquement
j'ai des biens systématiquement exclure
l'homme et processus voilà ça moi ça me
pousse à ça me pousse à réfléchir
surtout qu'on a des robots extrêmement
puissant qui sont en train d'arriver je
peux vous donner un autre exemple on a
on a des robots vos coups on a des
assistants vocaux qui sont en train
d'arriver dans les maisons c'est d'une
puissance phénoménale c'est extrêmement
intéressant vous dites à votre robot
voudrais avoir une bouteille de lait
puis la bouteille de lait à la rive
formidable si en plus mais j'ai donc
vous êtes une personne âgée ou ouais
vraiment c'est formidable c'est pas sale
jeu remis en cause sauf que sauf que
cette bouteille de lait comment il
m'arrive
il ya plein de façons la faire arriver
peut-être qu'elle va arriver en drones
d'un dépôt outre atlantique
ou peut-être que ça va m'être livrés par
l'épicier au coin de la rue et on
comprend bien que là c'est pas pareil
quoi c'est pas pareil après est-ce que
c'est mieux ou moins bien c'est pas moi
dire ça je pense qu' il appartient à
chacun de ceux de se faire son idée et
et se poser cette question c'est
important moi j'ai mis 35 ans à
comprendre
je suis désolé j'ai une conviction
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils nous restent
pas à 35 ans pour apprendre à faire ça
et à se poser une question très simple
qui est en faisant ce que je fais avec
les machines avec lequel je le fais
quelle est la société que je construis
et est-ce vraiment celle que je souhaite
merci
[Musique]